well on day 14 Louis swam a total of
eleven point three miles at 18
kilometers bring him to less than a
hundred miles from Dover well he will
end this marathon challenge skies thomas
moore was aboard lewis's boat and sent
this report it's 2:00 in the morning the
winds that forced Lewis Pugh to shelter
in Harbor on Sunday have eased and he's
using the lull in the weather to go for
a swim
storm Ernesto has put his 350 mile long
Odyssey along the length of the English
Channel behind schedule and he has
ground to make up the first challenge is
how to stay visible in the dark
it's a low-tech solution enough to
pinpoint his position but too dim to
help him see I don't see jellyfish I
don't see where the wave is breaking so
when I come up and I try and take a
breath I put a judge it as well as
possible but at night it's much more
challenging and so that I'll be
swallowing probably swelling a lot of
sea water tonight Lewis is seven miles
off the suttas coast and the exact GPS
position he finished the last leg the
anxious support team used torches to
guide him to Erie effect
Lewis's swim is all about peril just as
he is in jeopardy in these conditions so
the sea is vulnerable to from
overfishing climate change and plastic
pollution an hour in and a quick pit
stop I think
soon the Sun will rise and there will be
nice the skipper is responsible for
Lewis's safety trying to keep the boat
alongside him in heavy seas is a
challenge I feel sense of relief every
time he climbs back on board the
yachtsman don't like it when they have
men overboard a woman overboard in any
situation so every time he gets back on
I'm very relieved as dawn breaks over
beachy head nose ends the swim to five
miles closer to the finishing line you
really can't see anything you feel very
disorientated so you can't hear things
you can't see things you're on your own
in the middle of the black even my hands
in front of my face at the hardly see
until the Sun started coming up time to
refuel then rest and it'll do it all
again in a few hours time the long swim
is unrelenting
Thomas more sky news brightened and you
can find out more about sky ocean
rescues campaign at sky ocean rescue
calm and we will of course keep you
up-to-date on Louis's big swim